Hi everyone,
I should really be editing my book
today,
but,
um,
I thought I'd take a bit of time to
respond to something that happened
in the media today in the aftermath of
James Demaurice Google memo.
I know the coverage it's received.
A journalist named Steve Kovak wrote a
story for business insider called
Silicon Valley's liberal bubble has
burst and the culture war has arrived in
that article which discussed the memo.
He characterized myself and,
uh,
Stefan Molyneux a well known youtube
personality as far right.
What is article said specifically was
that,
and I quote Youtube,
which is ironically owned by Google and
has become a hotspot for right wing v
Loggers was they would let of choice for
Demora himself.
His first public interviews were to
Stefan Molyneux and Jordan b Peterson
far right figures who have built up
large followings on the video site.
And I felt that that was inappropriate,
let's say to say the least.
Um,
and so I tweeted that and emailed him
and said that that was a
mischaracterization and asked him to
justify his claims.
And so what I'm going to do is to read
our email exchange to,
okay,
um,
and you can draw your own conclusions
from it.
So
the first email,
this is my email,
I said,
dear Mr Kovach,
you called me a far right figure in
press.
You don't have one iota of proof for
that statement.
And it is patently untrue.
I've been lecturing,
for example,
about the dangers of national socialist
ideology for decades.
Find a single thing I've said that
places me on the far right in the
absence of a smoking pistol is that
grounds for a lawsuit for defamation of
character.
Inquiring minds want to know if you want
to talk,
I'm open to it,
but you should watch your words.
I'm seriously unhappy about you're
careless and false characterization.
Watch this,
for example,
and see if it's far right.
I link to a youtube video of a lecture I
gave on the temperamental basis of right
wing belief.
And so then Steve responded and he said,
how would you prefer to be
characterized?
And then he said,
just saw your tweets.
Please let me know what you would
prefer.
And so I said I would prefer the truth.
I would prefer that journalists such as
yourself use absolute precision of
language.
It's not up to me to tell you what that
is.
It's up to you given your choice of
profession.
And this is no laughing matter,
Mr Kovach as you seem to imply with
quote,
please let me know what you prefer.
And I've been fighting an intellectual
war against radicals on the right and
left for three decades.
I've been very clear and public track
record with regards to my attitude to
the far right.
I spent a lot of time and for example,
in my first book,
maps of meaning outlining the
psychopathology of national socialists
and it made my opposition to such things
known in a manner both public and widely
distributed.
The fact that I'm equally unhappy with
the gulag type leftists generally
ignored by the modern postmodernists
does not make me far right.
I'm seriously unhappy about being
carelessly lumped in with people I
despise and have spent my life fighting.
He wrote back and said,
thank you for your response.
So the article is truthful and accurate.
How would you like to be characterized?
I said,
I said very clearly you mischaracterized
me as far right on what grounds
whatsoever can you make that claim and
having made it,
it is your responsibility to either
justify the characterization with some
investigation or to withdraw it and
apologize politically.
I'm a classic British liberal.
Temperamentally.
I'm high in openness which tells me to
the left,
although I am also conscientious which
tells me to the right.
Philosophically,
I'm an individualist collectivist,
have the right or the left
metaphysically.
I'm an American pragmatist who has been
strongly influenced by the
psychoanalytic and clinical thinking of
Freud young and the psycho therapists
who have followed in their wake.
There is simply nothing I've said or
done that makes me far right.
Quite the contrary.
I've warned thousands of students over
the course of three decades that the
spirit of Auschwitz concentration camp
guards dwells in their heart and that
they should do everything in their power
to recognize it's existence and overcome
it.
Every single lecture of my maps of
meaning course,
various versions which have now been
watched or listened to by millions of
people,
make some variant of that point.
I've also produced a series of
individual self development programs now
used by thousands of people to
strengthen themselves as individuals
determine their proper and honorable
destinies and live productive,
meaningful lives.
You didn't do your homework.
You cast a serious dispersion on my
character.
I don't deserve it in the least.
I want you to do something about it.
He responds.
Thank you for the clarification,
Jordan.
I will correct the story and identify
you as a classic British liberal.
I responded.
I wrote this one before.
I received his response,
but I sent it after so I'm keeping it in
the order that it actually emerged
rather than in the order that it makes
precise sense.
Dear Mr. Colback,
do you really think that if I were far
right,
I could have placed 200 university
lectures online and taught for three
decades at Harvard and at the University
of Toronto without someone making a
devastating case for my ideological
perversity?
In what universe could that possibly
occur?
I'm a university professor,
clinical psychologists,
and a public intellectual whose primary
goal is the psychological and
metaphysical strength and fortification
of the individual.
I was still trying to clarify,
um,
how I would like to be referred to
literally nothing about that as far
right.
I don't even care though that you've
called me that name.
In the last year,
I've been called names by people who
have made that kind of behavior,
a well-practiced part of their
professional specialty.
What I care about is the fact that the
name is wrong,
seriously wrong.
You're engaged in a very important
public debate,
handled incorrectly.
That debate will degenerate into
conflict.
When you make an error,
willful or otherwise,
you increase the possibility of
catastrophe.
I'm calling your attention to such an
error.
To put it bluntly,
you are contributing to the dangerous
political polarization,
increasingly typifying public discourse.
By vilifying my views and my character,
it appears that you have done so either
carelessly or to add some narrative
punch to your story.
Neither of these reasons are in the
least justifiable post our email
dialogue publicly if you'd like.
Let the readers sorted out for
themselves.
If you want to stick to your guns,
and then I thought and replied,
that's okay.
All Post the dialogue.
Screenshots to twitter,
which I've done.
Steve Kovak responded,
thanks for your help.
The story has been corrected and without
Mr.
Kovak went online and changed his
description of both Stefan Molyneux and
from,
as I had mentioned previously,
far right to the current description,
which is right leaning,
Stefan Molyneux and classic British
liberal Jordan b Peterson,
which I might point out is quite a
substantial departure from the initial
thought.
Right.
You might think I'd be pleased about the
change and I suppose it's better the way
it is then the way it was,
but I'm not pleased at all with the fact
that it happened or really with the fact
that it was changed so easily.
It's like it's not a straightforward
matter.
It's not a matter of no import to
mischaracterize someone as far right,
especially in today's political climate
and it's indicative of what I would
describe as loose journalistic ethics,
uh,
to put it mildly.
To then be so willing to transform your
terminology with no explanation to your
reader and no apparent.
Let's call it crisis of conscience or
or serious consideration of the meaning
of your options.
Well,
that's not good.
Let's put it that way
anyways.
You guys can,
apart from that commentary,
which I couldn't stop myself from
making.
You guys can draw your own conclusions
and then one last thing.
I'm not exactly sure what to make of the
alt right and
yeah,
and then one last thing.
I'm not sure
what,
and then one last thing.
I'm not sure how to understand the old
right or to characterize it or even to
know what to think about.
It's hypothetical existence or my
association with it,
but I can tell you that I'm not in favor
of people banding together in
ideological groups and instead would
much rather see people live
fundamentally productive and meaningful
and honest individual lives and in that
manner be a light unto their neighbors,
so to speak,
to show the way to live in the world
without undue ideological possession and
to move forward things productively in
that manner.
I don't know of any pathway forward
through this increasingly polarized
political landscape that we find
ourselves in that isn't absolutely rife
with the possibility of conflict.
And if I haven't made that clear so far,
I would certainly like to make it clear
now.
So I would encourage those of you who
are considering yourself say on the old
right for that matter as well as on the
radical left too,
transcend your
dangerous and impersonal ideological
identification and start to live is true
individuals in the world.
Um,
that's what I think and I hope that I've
been communicating that.
And if I haven't,
well I apologize because that's what
I've been trying to do.